so what we're here to talk about is uh
Lance CB is the project that I'm working
on and the the title here is lightweight
but billion scale Vector search for
multimodal AI um so you know very
briefly about myself I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Lance CB uh I've been
making these uh tools for data
scientists and machine learning
Engineers for almost two decades uh once
upon a time I was one of the original
co-authors of the pandas library and
I've been doing um sort of similar
having similar roles since then uh most
recently I was VP of engineering at 2btv
uh a streaming company where I focus a
lot on mlops and recommender systems and
it was there that uh sort of got me uh
started on creating Lance format and
Lance CV uh basically uh by seeing all
the pain points that ml Engineers had to
go through to deal with managing all of
the unstructured data that we had from
from you know embeddings to um video and
and image assets and text and and
metadata and all that together um so uh
what is what what is Lan CB and what
what are we solving for so um you know I
think almost everyone in the whole world
who has internet access has access has
used chat GPT at some at this point in
time right and we've just barely passed
um the one one year uh birthday for chat
gbt now one of the things that people
have noticed with llms in general um is
that you know its knowledge is uh
limited right to what you feed into it
so then the problem is hallucination
when you ask questions about U things
that it doesn't know doesn't know about
it tends to make up
answers so and this is where rag comes
in uh or retrieval augmented generation
so if you can uh you can think of rag as
like you know an open book test where
you know you you go in to take the test
but you're allowed to have a reference
book with you and you can just find the
answers and this is a way to essentially
reduce or eliminate hallucinations and
extend the knowledge of llms um so you
know as folks build these applications
we realize that retrieval is absolutely
critical for AI data but um out of all
the choices that we have today with
Vector databases uh that power the such
retrieval it's actually kind of hard to
figure out which one you should use in
general um at least from from our users
you know when as they're evaluating they
say that it's hard to find a vector
database until they come to L CB that
has the rich features that they need and
it scales to production at a reasonable
price so uh if you think about all the
choices today Vector databases in
general cost a lot and um is more
complicated to run and it lacks a lot of
the data management features that we're
um familiar with already from
traditional databases on the other hand
there are a lot of traditional databases
that have added Vector
indices uh but the problem there is we
have limited scalability and there are
often no Advanced retrieval options so
depending on your use case and as you
scale up what a lot of our users are
finding is that they have to hop from
one option to the other and it's uh it
really kind of is too complicated or too
costly right so your your use cases can
change very quickly because you know AI
is is developing very rapidly and it's
very exciting but um your data
infrastructure should not because it's
just really expensive to switch data
infrastructure
so uh we'll talk about Lance CB how that
how we solve these problems and we'll
talk a little bit about the L's column
or format uh that powers Lan CB under
the hood and that makes it special and
then um we'll we'll go through a couple
of demos to to show you what Lan CB is
capable of and then we'll finish up with
what we're working on um down the road
now Lan CB is an open source inprocess
Vector database uh and we think that it
gives the bo the best of both Vector
databases and traditional
databases what in process means is that
it runs in the same process as your
application it's an or another word for
it is an embedded database where it um
you don't need to spin up another server
or worry about operations and connecting
to it um it's like SQ or. DB right Lance
DB is written with a rust core and has
Python and typescript bindings and
there's lots of handcrafted Sim decode
for just absolute crazy performance and
um it's super scalable it's very cost
effective um and it is built natively
with multimodal data management meaning
images videos text so on and so forth in
mind U so I alluded to this when we
talked about in process right so uh Lan
CB is incredibly lightweight so you can
install it in seconds and it runs in
process if you're familiar with sqlite
or duck DB Lan CV is essentially sqlite
or dug DB for Vector search but don't
let the lightweight package fool you
it's incredibly scalable um because
everything runs on disk and has all the
simp um optimizations I talked about on
just a single node even on my laptop you
can get to a billion vectors uh without
breaking a sweat and we've added GPU
acceleration for indexing to speed that
up at scale um and it's the only option
that offers separation of compute and
storage and we'll see why that matters
in a little
bit L CB is also really full featured um
you know it's a it's a open source
Vector database that delivers um both
like hybrid vector and um full Tech
searches metadata filtering SQL and what
a lot of our users find really awesome
about L CB is that we have a very native
level integration into the tools that
you're familiar with in Python like
pandas and polar and duct DB um and even
into like spark or or slurm if you're
coming from an academic lab um on on the
other hand uh Lan CB unlike other Vector
databases comes with um a lot of the the
features for data management that you
would expect from a traditional database
so you can have arbitrary number of
vector columns arbitrary metadata
columns that you can search through um
you know concurrent rights uh
lightweight transactions and very
scalable reads with with some invidual
consistency right and so
um before before we get into what uh
Powers Lan CB under the hood um I can we
can um just show you a little bit about
what lanb can do so let me just share a
separate screen here um so what's
interesting what's interesting here is a
um I call it a multimodal Search
application so as you can see from this
notebook um let me just yeah there we
go yeah this should be okay uh I'm just
importing Lan CB and I'm connecting to
my local uh directory here and what
we're going to do today is actually just
look through the um Oxford pep data set
which has got a bunch of really cute
cats and dogs and we're going to search
through them using using vectors right
so um what we're going to do is say use
the open clip multimodal uh model here
to do the vectorization and U of course
we can use MPS I'm running on a MacBook
um and it's pretty easy to declare the
schema here uh using pedantic you can
say there's a vector column there's
specii as the metadata and then there's
for that image um and we're going to
open that table and we can just
basically see I can say table. search uh
a French Bulldog and I can show the
three most similar um the
images and indeed the first one comes uh
with a cute little French Bulldog here
what what's really cool about Lance TV
is that because of the integration that
we have with arrow and and the python
ecosystem we can actually search
directly uh with with the image so I've
got this picture of really cute uh baby
suad here and uh what we can do is feed
that query image right this this query
image variable here um into the search
so I can say table. search um and then
show me the top three and then just
display the the first one so indeed we
get a pretty similar looking fluffy
little dog here uh what's really what's
really interesting about Lan CV here
unlike other Vector databases is it's
built with production in mind so what
that means is every operation that you
do with updates and so on and so forth
It's tracked um and it's you can have
instant roll back and have uh time
travel so for example if I accidentally
deleted all of um let's say I deleted
all of the Cats in this data set right
so if I look at this data set in this
stage
everything everything's kind of a dog
what I can do is actually say okay just
give me back I I don't want to delete
all the cats I want the cats back you
know just give me back to the previous
version restore it and now I've got both
cats and dogs back um
again um and then uh one last thing I
wanted to show here
is the uh I mentioned scale right so I
had a screenshot but I I just wanted to
make that a little bit real um
and um hopefully air meat uh air meat's
not going to let me share a separate
screen here
um okay I'm not
sure
uh yeah I'm not sure how I'm going to do
this actually oh I know I know I can do
this should be pretty easy all right so
we can go back to the The Notebook
actually
um and and uh so if you bear with me so
I've got Lan CB here and um there's a
table uh
called test
1B right and if I if we look at the
table this thing has um what is it one
you know one billion vectors in it and
so um what I'm going to do is just say
time um table.
search import unpi and then um table
about
search I'm going to generate a random
Vector just to to um show the search
here and then limit
three to
errow um yeah so I've got this thing
here and and so what I can do is show
the timing here
uh and it's going to run in a loop and
you can see um within a few milliseconds
right for each search on a billion
vectors on just my MacBook U I'm able to
run that search and so what this means
is that if you've you know maybe uh for
your earlier uh experimentation you
don't have that many vectors but scale
really sneaks up on you so in production
it's very easy to say hey I'm going to
try out a couple different chunking
strategies and all of a sudden I've got
like 10 times the the vector as I was
expecting before right so um a lot of
other Vector databases as the scale
becomes very expensive uh you know Lan
CB of course like it's you know it's
open source um so it reduces the cost
but it even in terms of infrastructure
it's an order to magnitude cheaper to
actually operate uh the uh the Lan CB
insulation in in production
um okay so let me take a pause so we got
a question in chat here uh looks like
it's a where were the embeddings being
calculated when you input a text or
image query that is a that's a great
question um yeah and I think
I like ran through that a little bit too
quickly here
um so if you look at the so what we can
do is when we look at the table U lanv
comes with an embedding function
registry and so here for this table
because we're doing text image search
we're saying uh get the open clip model
out of that registry now this registry
is is um extensible so you can write
your own you can add your own and then
what we're going to do with this model
is configure that into the table schema
so it's very uh since we have access to
python here we can use pantic to make it
super easy to to declare the data model
that we're working with so you have a
vector that's your embedding and then I
can use the model to say hey this is my
Vector field and then this Vector has
the same number of Dimensions as my
model and then um I'm going to say so
you know for for the clip model because
I'm encoding the the um images I can say
hey this U this URI string column is the
source data for that field so when I add
um when I add data into it for this
table I only have to add the image
column or the the URI column I don't
have to worry about the vectors and then
when I search on it I can I can just add
a text or the image and depending on
whether the input is a text or a string
or a a pill image uh the Lan CB table
figures out um how to interact with the
model under the hood so that you don't
even have to worry about the embedding
process at all
right um cool yeah hope that that
answered the
question all right cool um all right
let's get back to the presentation a
little bit
and um I guess we won't have too much
time to go through the uh Lance format
so I might speed through some of these
slides happy to take more time to answer
any questions um so uh what I think is
the secret sauce behind Lance CB is what
we call L colum or format and um this is
a new colum or format kind of like par
and orc but it's a uh spe it's a format
that's specially optimized for AI data
um and generally that means you know
images video Point clouds vectors and so
on so so forth so um it's it's colum
format so it's fast for scans like with
traditional bi queries and analytics
queries but what we found before we
started designing this this colum format
was for a lot of AI and machine learning
need uh workflows we need fast random
access uh for shuffling for sampling
debugging evals uh in and of course
Vector search and Par and orc are
designed um are not designed to deliver
fast random access and and what Lance
does is because it lays out the data
differently and has a different um
scanner it's able to deliver uh 100x
performance for those types of AI
workloads that critically depend on fast
random access and uh what's most
interesting about Lance is that it's
both a file format kind of like parquet
that uh and it's also a table format so
you can think of it like a lightweight
um you know Iceberg or Delta for AI data
so that gives us a lightweight
transactions uh it gives us the
secondary indices which Powers the
vector database on top of those L files
and it gives us like versioning and and
roll backs and time travel and things
like that so um if you think about like
Lance as a format it's it's an Onis
format like paret um the main interface
is Apache arrow and that's the inmemory
representation of the data right and at
the compute layer uh it's well
integrated into Data frame SQL engines
and of course Lan CB the vector
database right and so uh and the main
reason why uh we chose Arrow as a
standard here is because it's much
easier to integrate into the the
ecosystem so you know by integrating
with arrow uh we we all of a sudden
make it make Lance format able to be
accessed by you know pandas and polar
and duct DB and all the python ecosystem
and of course migration is very easy
conversion is literally two lines of
code one to read it into into Arrow one
to write it into Lance
format um in general Lance format is
used in a couple of different um buckets
right so large scale data mining for
autonomous vehicles for example
generative AI train data lake so we've
got users that have uh converted
pedabytes of image data for training
debugging and Vector search obviously
and then uh semantic search for llms
rexus and generative AI um and where we
deliver single node low ly Vector
search um so one of the things that we
sort of took take a look at is you know
recently there was a um paper from you
know Andy Pavo ATU and Wes mckenny on
the performance of par and orc for
Vector search and ml workload so we
replicated some of those benchmarks and
we can show you here that you know uh on
both SSD and on S3 Lance drastically
outperforms our the existing formats so
something that you if you compare to
parquet if you're um if you're familiar
with that right Lance is basically
single digit milliseconds here to just
effect effect
the fetch the vector search results
whereas paret takes you know close to a
second um the situation is revers
between parane orc on S3 B Lance remains
very very uh
performant so um I'll take just about
two minutes talk uh just mention the
things that makes Lance different so um
you know the binary encoder in Lance
lays out the data differently from par
so in par if you have
a a string like this the offsets and the
and the data are interl so you have you
know offset data offset data so that's
why you're not able to actually uh get
fast random access but with uh Lance we
actually store the offsets separately
from the data so that you can have
constant a constant offset read and then
a constant data
read the uh IO the scanner is also very
different and it's optimized for
large blob data um in particular uh if
you have a query like this like select
from you know with some filters and
limit offset the traditional on the left
you see the traditional IO plan for an
olap type of query where you know at the
bottom is where you read out all of the
columns from the select and the wear and
then you go through the rest of that
query so the the problem is if you're
fetching like lar cloud data each CL lar
Cloud can be you know up to like 100
megabytes or something so you're wasting
a lot of IO on that initial scan because
you're going to filter it later so
instead here we do late
materialization and um what we do is
only only fetch the predicate columns
the filter columns and then we we do the
fetch for the projection at the very end
in a take and of course this requires
fast random access to to actually make
sense um and then Lance also gives us
zeroc copy schema Evolution so that you
know kind of like Iceberg and Par uh
what you can do is you can add rows and
add columns after the data set has been
written and of course you can roll back
to previous versions and you don't have
to copy that data right this matters a
lot uh especially for ML data if you
have like a petabyte of images and you
want to do some experiments add some
features you don't want to have to copy
the whole data set just to add a a new
column right um
um yeah so the last thing I'll mention
here before I open up uh for questions
is um you know it it turns out that the
uh Random Access performance of um of
Lance's format is makes it a great fit
for adding in secondary indices in this
case a vector index so that we can have
a vector index that's written on disk
that points to certain rows um in the
the the corresponding rows in the data
set and we can fetch that really really
really quickly um and so this is this is
what gives Lance CB the flexibility and
also the
scalability it's all powered by U the
design of L format all right so Lance is
essentially we call this open platform
for machine learning and AI to build on
um so you know from uh ETL and updates
to analytics model training and Vector
search uh can all have a single source
of truth right we're working on some
really awesome things uh partition
pruning and scaler indices are are
already done and and just shipped we're
going to be writing some more docs and
uh uh blog post about that and there's a
lot of exciting work especially uh
number three and Advan en codings so
there are um recent work by like various
uh research Labs like the bitter block
paper and priscella paper from Google um
all with some very interesting things
that we're going to incorporate and
maybe collaborate with those groups um
but yeah so um I think this is uh yeah
I'm going to leave a few minutes for
questions U please check us out if
you're building generative AI
applications or managing multimodal data
at scale so our open source uh repo or
open source or glance CV has three main
repos that you should pay attention to
for examples you can go to Vector dv-
recipes for the format it's just Lance
DV Lance and then the open source Vector
database is lanb lanb um and feel free
to email us at contact lanb.com we're
working on a cloud version uh if you're
interested in hosting it for for
production cool um yeah sped through the
second half of that talk a little bit
but I wanted to leave a few minutes for
questions um
cool so how would it work for boml such
protein character as a class yeah that's
that's a great question so uh we're
working on sort of generic support for
different data types at for Vector
representations um so I think for biom
ML like the thing that's um missing
right now is support for uh like Boolean
vectors uh or like really in eight
vectors so you can certainly encode um
protein structures or or um you know the
bit vectors as like float float 16 or
something like that and you can
calculate cosine distance just fine so
at at small scale this already works
just fine um at I think at larger scale
the um the storage uh starts to matter a
little bit so we'll be looking to add
support for those and then um if you're
working with like Boolean vectors then
you may want to use you may end up want
wanting to use like jakar distance
instead of like cosine or something like
that um but cosine should be should work
uh okay I
think okay
um hope that answers the question uh
next one if you need to embed
a uh a billion vectors you'd want to
parallelize that how would you then
index those into right yeah so um I
think uh there's there's a couple of
strategies so the one that we've been
working on is actually just to make it
really fast which and that uses the GPU
um so we are uh we we've shipped a bunch
of GPU acceleration for indexing and
then there's a uh there's some more that
are coming
um so uh I think for like for a billion
vectors uh you should be able to get it
to like an acceptable time uh on just a
single GPU machine I think that's in
general easier to manage than um like
having a distributed system but that's
also kind of in the
works okay can you host land CV on your
own kubernetes or a VM environment on
Prem if so what are the requirement
right right yeah yeah this is totally
possible um and it's actually very easy
to do so um
the it's it's kind of like if you were
writing an application and you wanted to
use sqlite or something like that to
interact with data uh so in general
there's a couple of uh so Lance CB
interfaces with tons of storage uh
Technologies so we can talk to S3
directly we can talk to like a mount of
drive like EFS or EBS
so you have a bunch of options so if
you're not super latency sensitive but
you're cost sensitive you can store the
data directly on S3 and you can just uh
you know run Lance TV in your
application interact with S3
directly if you're super latency
sensitive but not super cost sensitive
uh you can store data on like EBS volume
and then in kubernetes you can have like
reader and writer pods on the same host
and just talking to that same uh EBS
volume for